it's been almost a decade since Steve
Jobs unveiled the original iPhone today
Apple is going to reinvent the phone
jobs was right about that the phone
itself was cool but it was the software
inside the iPhone that really changed
everything with the 10th version of iOS
just about to come out it's tempting to
look back at all the ways iOS has
changed the way we live our lives and
it's equally tempting to think that it
all starts with the touchscreen remember
when you used to have to use a trackball
or a stylus to navigate around your
phone with the iPhone you could just use
your finger or two fingers or ten
fingers nothing had ever been like that
before except it totally had the first
touch screens were invented in the 70s
multi-touch and even pinch-to-zoom have
been around since at least the early 90s
the revolutionary thing about iOS wasn't
the touch screen it was that from the
very beginning the software had the low
latency and laws of motion to really
sell the illusion of direct manipulation
when you use the iPhone you weren't
touching the screen you were reaching
through it to touch whatever was on the
other side it's also the kind of
physical interaction that's so key to
what made the iPhone work when you
scrolled on an iPhone it's like you're
just swiping a piece of paper up and off
the screen everything has size and
weight and it feels like it's a real
thing instead of just pictures on a
screen
pretty much everything Apple is done
with iOS since then has hinged on that
one trick with one exception Siri what
is the weather like today
here's the forecast for today it is that
easy but have you used Siri lately it's
not always that easy
yes it's gotten way better in the last
few years and it's spread to products
like Apple watch and Apple TV but more
often than it should series still leaves
us feeling like Phil Schiller back in
2011 we have very limited capability you
just learn the syntax call a names dial
a number play a song it is such a
letdown apples working on that but then
so is everyone else since then we're
kind of waiting for the next big thing
Apple already changed the world once
with iOS if it's gonna do it again it's
gonna have to be with Siri